In the last few years, there have been
a lot of breathless news articles
about the upcoming shortage of chocolate.
Around the world, demand for chocolate is
rising, particularly in China and India,
and the supply isn't matching it.
It turns out that the cocoa beans
that get turned into chocolate
are a really difficult crop to grow.
Cocoa needs fairly specific
climate conditions.
It needs a lot of management.
And about 30 to 40% of the entire world's
crop of cocoa
is just lost to pests
and diseases every year.
So what the modern world needs is new,
hardier, more pest
resistant varieties of cocoa
with higher yields.
Botanists
send plant cuttings around the world,
so they can cross
breed them and see what the results are.
But the trouble is: if you're sending
cuttings around the world,
you might be sending diseases with them,
and that could be devastating.
Which is why in a rural bit
of southern England, there
sits the International Cocoa
Quarantine Center.
- The quarantine process
lasts for two years.
The reason why it is so long
is because viruses
can potentially stay latent in the plant
for a long period of time.
We generally receive plant material
from what we call
"gene banks",
so these are the research centers
that have collections of lots
of different types of cocoa plants.
That plant material arrives
as what we call "bud sticks".
We will inspect that material
in the laboratory, make sure there's
no signs of fungal spores
or insects on it.
But whilst it's quite easy to spot a pest
or a fungal problem,
viral diseases can be much more difficult
to spot.
- When a researcher or grower orders
a cutting from here, they know that
they won't also get something nasty
that could infect their
existing cocoa crop
or even their entire region's cocoa crop.
But what they'll receive
isn't the original plant that was sent in.
This isn't like quarantine for parcels
or for people.
They don't take an incoming cocoa plant,
put it in the bit of this warehouse
that I'm not allowed to be in because it's
quarantined, and then just send it on.
After the two years' quarantine,
the center here has a known safe plant,
one of these that I'm actually allowed
to stand near, and then they can send
cuttings out on request,
over and over and over again.
- There are other quarantine centers
for other plants.
There's a quarantine facility
for bananas, for example.
I believe there's one in Scotland
for potatoes.
A particular thing about cocoa
is that a lot of the pests
and diseases of cocoa are only found
in particular geographical regions.
If growers can be supplied with plants
which are more resilient to these threats,
so more resilient to pests and diseases,
and more resilient
to extreme temperatures, then that helps
in securing the future of the crop.
- There is one obvious question, of course,
if all the unsafe cocoa
that might have pests in it is sitting
somewhere around here in rural England...
what if one of those pests escapes?
- In the UK, we don't grow cocoa.
It's too cold,
but that's actually a positive thing
in terms of the location
of the quarantine center.
So the fact that we're located
in a country that does not grow cocoa
means there's
no risk of pests and diseases
which are endemic to cocoa
entering the facility.
So if we were to receive any material
which had a nasty disease,
that material would be discarded.
It would be autoclaved
just as a precaution, but
the chance of it
establishing here would be almost zero.
- If there does end up being a worldwide
cocoa shortage,
it doesn't mean that the grocery store
shelves will end up empty.
It just means that the price of chocolate
will rise and rise and rise
as supply falls.
And the big manufacturers
would very much like to make sure
that chocolate
does not go back to being a luxury.
And the folks here at the quarantine
center
are doing their bit
to make sure that doesn't happen.